então essa é a pergunta afinal que os
bebês fazem no berçário para fazer para
falar sobre isso vou te contar duas
historinhas pra vocês se vocês me
permitem o ted permitiu então começa
quando eu era bailarino fratura o meu
ombro ea única coisa que eu sabia fazer
na época era dançar não podia mais
dançar profissionalmente então fui
dançar com as crianças quando foi
trabalhar como professor de dança para
crianças
me encantei foi capturado pela forma
particular e peculiar que as crianças
inter pelo mundo
as crianças perguntam sobre o mundo e
por conta disso resolvi ficar com elas
estão até hoje
depois de algum tempo como professor de
dança é professor de uma turma de
crianças de 3 anos uma turma referência
a gente chama de professor referência e
sendo professor dessas crianças por
algum tempo fui continuando me
perguntando a respeito sobre a docência
entendendo algumas coisas que afinal de
contas já tinha sido aluno e já estava
estudando a respeito
depois de algum tempo me chamam para ser
coordenador de escola e aí começa a
minha questão com os bebês
na época bebês para mim era alguma coisa
bonitinha que eu passava de vez em
quando nas salas e dizia olha que
lindinhos só que sendo o coordenador
isso já não era mais suficiente e eu
tive que entender a respeito
foi um ano difícil porque eu não sabia
muito a respeito dos bebês mas fui
perseguindo para tentar entender não
fiquei contente senão só coordenador e
resolvi ser professor de bebê se imagina
o que essa professora os bebés se
imaginam dando aula através a questão é
exatamente essa toda gramática que a
gente tem sobre ser professor não cabe
para os bebês
eu não sabia disso e fui professor da
bbs e fui fazer aquilo que eu sabia
fazer que dava certo com as crianças
maiores
então no meu primeiro dia com uma turma
de 12 bebês de 4 meses a 14 meses sentei
e fui contar uma história
pedi para auxiliar me ajudar pois os
bebês próximos e quando começa o quanto
a história os bebês me olham olham para
o livro esse escape - aqueles que não
conseguiram se deslocar e bem tiveram
que ficar ali por perto eu repetir
algumas vezes ea quanta coisa continua
não dando certo
naquele dia eu entendi que tudo que eu
sabia sobre ser professor não servia
para o professor da bbs continua a
investigar sobre esse foi o que me
mobilizou a entrar no mestrado e fazer
essa pergunta afinal o que os bebês
fazem no berçário
a questão é que eu me deparo com uma
literatura que vai falar o que fazer com
os bbbs ea pergunta a outra é que os
bebês fazem aniversário começa a fazer
uma investigação sobre isso e aí aqui
está a segunda história que é a história
do carlos aliás antes da história do
carlos tem história do caio e aí vou
pedir pra vocês licença para contar a
segunda história começa eu vou
acompanhar então nove bebês no princípio
no meu mestrado bebês de 6 a 14 meses
com dois adultos estáveis dois
professores estáveis com esses bebês no
interior do rio grande do sul
estou acompanhando eles para entender
aquilo que eu chamei do que os bebês
fazem os espaços vazios espaços que tem
o frescor da vida no meu entendimento
são espaços em que o adulto não está
interpelando intervindo de forma direta
ou não está dizendo faça assim eu queria
saber o que os bebês faziam fariam sem
que um adulto que se faça assim fui ver
chegar então esses bebês foi acompanhar
esses nove bebês descobrir aliás
acompanhando esses nove bebês que um
deles mais ou menos 13 meses era um dos
mais idosos do grupo não quis participar
da pesquisa
e obviamente que ele não me disse isso
dizendo olha paulo eu não vou assinar o
termo de consentimento informado
mas ele me falou de outras formas e
começa uma pista interessante a gente
tem que se especializar numa linguagem
que não é da palavra para lidar com
bebês
talvez por eu ter sido bailarino me
ajudou porque eu lido com a linguagem
corporal dos bebês
é isso que me conecta ex bom descobrir
que esse bebê não queria participar e
dos nove ficam 18 estava olhando que os
bebês faziam sem a menor sem a
intervenção direta do adulto a neide a
professora personagem importante passar
um final de semana preparando uma caixa
para os bebês descobrirem o celofane
gado dentro dela tinha a ideia era que
os bebês achassem pane para olhar o sol
pra ver a incidência de 12 e acreditem
isso é o máximo que os bebês estão
chegando o mundo que estão vivendo a
pedagogia dos começos bota caixa no meio
da sala os bebês estão brincando e ela
começa a puxar eles para brincar com a
caixa
ela faz o mesmo que eu fiz quando quis
contar a história
um ponto importante sobre o professor da
bbs a gente não supõe que eles têm a
agência a gente não supõe que eles
querem que eles desejam e que eles não
querem eles não desejam que a gente faz
atropela colonista reuniu todos eles que
estavam fazendo alguma coisa pela sala
felizes concentrados compenetrados e
puxa para fazer o que ela queria o bb a
caixa
olham e se escapam
- o caio o bebê bem novo que ainda não
se desloca e por isso ele não se escapa
da caixa
só que o caio tem um papel super
importante nessa história isso vai se
repetindo a neide vai ficando muito
tensa porque pra azar dela eu estou lá
fazendo a pesquisa exatamente neste dia
isso vai se repetindo a neide tenta de
tudo inclusive uma voz mais sedutora
olha que trouxe os bebês não se rendem a
coisa continua ficando cada vez mais
tensa
até que em um certo momento e até hoje
eu realmente penso sobre isso eu acho
que os bebês se compadecem a média
porque afinal de contas ela era muito
legal com eles e é uma pessoa muito
incrível eles devem pensar bom paulo
aqui pesquisando vamos ajudar prof
é legal ea eles param finalmente ao
redor da caixa mas eles não chegam no
celofane quando eles param finalmente ao
redor da caixa
lucas que é um outro bebê de
aproximadamente uns dez meses
olha para o que o caio estava fazendo lá
o tempo inteiro porque lembrem o caio
não saiu de lá né
e aí se dá conta que o carro estava o
tempo inteiro futucando o dedo um
papelão corrugado e sem nenhuma palavra
lucas se dá conta disso o kaio se dá
conta que o lucas percebeu o que estava
fazendo e sorri como quem quer dizer
rio você estava por aí passeando e eu
estava tirando maior som que besteira
essa fiquem aqui e os dois começam um
diálogo sem nenhuma palavra
os dois continuam mas lembra que nessa
altura do campeonato já muito preocupada
ela vai lá e acaba surpresa e puxo
celofane e diz olha o que tem aqui os
bebês olham celofane finalmente atendem
ao fetiche adulto encontrar agora deu
certo
quando nós vamos olhar para as imagens
que eu fiquei fazendo durante esse tempo
da pesquisa
a gente se dá conta de coisas
importantes sobre a construção da bbc
primeiro negando que eles estavam
fazendo alguma coisa antes da caixa de
telefone e segundo o que tinha de tão
importante para que todos tivessem que
descobrir a caixa de celofane
da mesma forma ao mesmo tempo porque
esse é não só o fetiche do professor do
berçário e seu fetiche de todo o
professor que todos aprendam da mesma
forma da mesma maneira ao mesmo tempo
isso nos deu que pensar e aí vem a
história do carlos
o carlos é o oposto do caio carlos é o
idoso da turma
tem 16 meses vejam que é o velho e ele
sendo mais velho ele começou a caminhar
recentemente como alguém que começou a
caminhar recentemente ele quer descobrir
o mundo ele quer investigar o mundo por
um outro horizonte que não é mais
deitado e aí começa a história
o carlos nós preparamos uma sessão
porque nós começamos fazer perguntas nos
preparamos uma sessão com materiais do
uso cotidiano da vida cotidiana cones
panelas rolos colheres porque de um lado
a teoria nos morre respeito dos bebês
nos mostra como esses materiais dão o
que pensar então o que fazer
por um outro lado se alguém aqui é pai
ou mãe sabe que quando o bebê começa a
engatinhar o primeiro lugar que ele vai
atacar em casa é a pia é a cozinha são
as panelas e sondado para a gente pensar
porque ele se interessa mais por uma
panela do que por um super hiper
brinquedo
na pesquisa a gente tem se dado conta de
algumas questões interessantes diz uma
autora alemã que é uma forma da gente
pertence à cultura quando a gente começa
a dominar esses usos dos objetos da
nossa da nossa cultura pois bem
preparamos uma sessão para que as
crianças investigassem a materialidade
o carlos estava lá na janela olhando
para fora como alguém que diz eu
conhecesse para que a van do ele e vocês
estão me deixando aqui dentro mas ok
vamos tirar proveito disso e ele vai
investigar o material e encontra um rolo
de papel e começa a testar na janela
tira coloca tira coloca quando ele faz
isso e fazer isso repetidamente
acontece que em um determinado momento
esse cano tranca quem quer dizer nada
carlos a como a fórmula de basca na 7ª
série
se o professor vai lá e faz por aluno
acaba com a possibilidade de ele pensar
respeito à neide essa altura do
campeonato já muito sacada sobre ser
professora de bebês
ela diz ela encoraja ele
diz carlos o que aconteceu o que você
vai fazer
ela recupera isso que nós perdemos que é
supor que o bb tem agência que ele pode
fazer o que neste momento pode ser
necessário para resolver o seu grande
problema
o cano trancou o carlos tenta tenta
tenta até que ele destravar o cano e aí
descobre uma grande coisa que as coisas
passam pela janela ea partir daí ele
começa a jogar tudo pela janela
não é só o carlos que repete o que ele
descobre minha mãe por exemplo quando
ela descobriu uma receita de bolo
a gente a comer aquele bolo por um mês
porque ela é fazer esse bolo
repetidamente a tela apreender e c dela
aquele bolo que o carro estava fazendo
até que ele jogou uma colher de pau ea
colher de pau ficou preso na janela ele
se dá conta que ela fica presa não só se
dá conta como resolve empurrar ela e
descobre a segunda coisa é que as coisas
podem passar as coisas podem ficar
presas continua sua pesquisa se passam
20 minutos se o carro está jogando
coisas para fora tinha muita coisa aí
ele joga uma lata a lata faz barulho e
ele descobre uma terceira coisa
as coisas podem passar pela janela as
coisas podem ficar presa e as coisas
podem fazer barulho o grande mistério
dele foi quando ele jogou uma esponja
esponja passou não ficou presa mas não
fez barulho aonde está a esponja
até hoje ele deve se perguntar sobre
isso foi indo se passam 30 40 minutos e
ele vai testar e se o banco passa testa
de um jeito testa do outro descobre uma
quarta coisa que tem questões que não
tem coisas que não vão passar pela
janela
essa história do carlos fez entender uma
coisa muito importante que os bebês
desejam que os bebês têm intenção que os
bebês querem e que portanto quando a
gente chegou morta buchecha dele belisca
ou para lá eles não gostam disso quando
a gente vai por trás da vida deles e
bota a mão gelada para ver se tem alguma
coisa eles não gostam disso
então o que nós aprendemos com os bebês
tem agência que eles gostam que eles não
gostam que eles sentem que eles pensam
é algo que eu diria para vocês que nós
podemos pensar sobre toda e qualquer
sala de aula do presente
obrigado
[Aplausos]